[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
plenary panel a lively discussion titled
challenges and opportunities of
artificial intelligence in neuroscience
and explainability this webinar is part
of the 11th annual event in the
Neuroscience virtual event series and
I'm Susie Valdez of labroots and I will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labots so let's get started
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our live chat feature
during this presentation you can find
that live chat chat located on the left
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during this presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click submit now we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of this presentation finally if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation just click on that
help desk button located at the top of
your screen within the navigation bar or
from the lobby I now want to present
today's speakers Dr Chang shuang an icon
postdoctoral fellow at MIT Dr gyo Che ke
principal research staff and manager at
TJ Watson IBM research and Dr Conrad
cording will be joining them he will be
moderating the discussion and he's from
the University of penssylvania and
co-founder of neurom match for a
complete biography of our speakers
please visit the presenter tab from the
menu at the left of your screen
gentlemen welcome you may now begin your
presentation oh wonderful as your
moderator Conrad my goal today will be
for us to have a wonderful discussion
with high clarity about everything we
talk about and a wonderful Community
spirit I guess I'm carrying that over
from your match so today's go goal is to
talk about challenges and opportunities
of artificial intelligence in
neuroscience and explainability much of
my research has been at the intersection
of these words there was early on a lot
about bringing artificial intelligence
into neuroscience and then recently I've
been very concerned about explainability
and I've been asking a lot of questions
and um this little presentation I mostly
see this as an opportunity to introduce
myself and so that we know who we are so
that we can talk with one another even
better so let's jump right in so in the
first part of my career I worked in a
supremely explainable part of
Neuroscience or behavior however you
want to call it which is the field of
basian behavior so here's the our newest
paper in that area if you have a
baseball uh play player the pitcher
throws the ball now the batter has to
estimate where the ball will come in and
you can say there is a priety
distribution of where the batter should
expect the ball to land and then there's
a probaby distribution induced by seeing
the ball fly and ultimately the better
will have to combine both of them in
that area basian mods have been very
established now basian Ms were the
quintessential part of artificial
intelligence for a long time within the
the field now of course over the last
few years things have very much moved to
neural
networks but there was a wonderful thing
about basian models which is they always
only use a handful of variables like in
this case I might be interested in how
high is the
ball and uh and um then I need to
estimate that and I have
uncertainty and what don't know my
typical model might contain three
variables or if it's really comp ated
model it might contain five
variables and they have simple
relationships I can explain to you and
that's what that feeli does how
variables relate to one another know the
balls being thrown there's a visual
stimulus being produced we can take that
stimulus Away by showing you blindness
or something like that so it it the
models are simple they have a small
number of variables and the components
of that we can really
understand now at the same time I was
always doing
Neuroscience so let's look at different
system but in this case you can say this
is supremely explainable and in that
sense it's if you want a Cornerstone of
this space that we're talking about it's
not very neural like what what these
people don't know what's happening in
brains because no one knows what's
really happening in brains because it
has so many Nuance but like at the same
time they also it's not very artificial
intelligence it just uses a little
sliver of that but it's very very
explainable so let's look at something
else here so here's another paper that
really shaped my thinking for a long
period of time it's uh the so-called
microprocessor paper with with Eric
Jas where you can take a microprocessor
and it's very explainable I mean it's
explainable to the level that we will
take our PhD students in computer
science or electrical engineering and we
will explain a classical microprocessor
to them so in that sense we know that
there exists a way of describing that
microprocessor but at the same time if
we use methods from Neuroscience to it
we will not understand how the
microprocessor work it's not explainable
in a way it's just explainable in a
certain way using the language of
computer scientists the language of of
processor design so what we had found
there is you can look at the properties
of transistors and analyze it the same
way as neuroscientists might analyze
results from Neons in the brain and what
we found is in a way transistor Behavior
looks similar to brains but this is all
a misleading description of what's
really going on so what we have there is
it's very explainable it's just not
explainable with what neuroscientists
usually do now like to again see where
this lies in this space and like there's
no artificial intelligence here be
beside from some properties of the
methods that we have it's very
explainable and it kind of highlights
this contrast that we have that
explanations might exist but we might
not know if we're even moving towards
explanations now here's another recent
paper um which was written with Blake
Richards and Tim and a lot of others
where we ask the question well would an
artificial NE Network actually be
explainable and in a way it is now I can
take the page code that makes your
neural network and I can go with through
it with you line by line no prom by the
way this isn't like actually real code
this is just C GPT generated Network
code but we can go through the code and
look through that and every line that
chat GPT wrote here I could understand
the first time I see it so it's very
explainable in that way but then we take
this neural network and we train it on a
terabyte of of data and then we ask can
we then understand the resulting Network
the network now is just a set of
basically large tensor of the weight
tensors that characterize what's going
on and in this case you can say it's not
understandable it's not explainable it's
like explainable in the sense that all
the information is on the paper but it's
certainly not explainable in the way
that a human can look at that and really
make sense out of that I think this is a
really interesting contrast that in a
way in the space of neural network
designs it's explainable but in the
space of neural network computation it's
profoundly not and I think brains are a
little bit maybe similar where the ways
how brains are made based on stimul life
from the outside world they depend on
the statistics of the outside world they
depend on you seeing that conred has
blue hair in a way that's going to be
smeared all over the brain into into
lots of synapses that now carry that and
so the resulting weight matrices in the
brain will be very very hard to
understand at least if we agree that the
world is complex the way I see the world
it's full of
complexity and then you can say well if
we want to arguably what Neuroscience
does at the moment is what we see here
on the right hand side now we stick an
electrode into a neuron and we see how
it depends on the inputs that's that's
literally trying to measure the measure
the weight Matrix or at least the
product of the fast C weight
matrices and and so arguably we need to
focus more on the way we do it on the
left of like understand brains as the
code that gives rise to computation and
now I want to just show two slides from
U from um from that new P from that
paper with Richards and many other
people at that new or a ioner what are
the things about brains that we should
be hoping to understand well the
objective functions what are the
objective functions are they being
optimized in which way are they being
optimized that's definitely one of the
things that we should hope to get out of
this space and I think it's this it's if
if I wear my AI hat this is what I want
neuroscientist to do because if we
understand what brains optimized we
could build that into artificial systems
but it same time it's a it's a nice
highlevel way of describing the way um
any system that is optimized for
something
behaves and then you can say the other
thing that's of course Very explainable
are architectures we do that extensively
when we design on all networks now we
talk about Transformers and recurrent
systems and uh conet and all the
different things so architectures are
very explainable like they they're one
of of the things that we explain and
arguably what a lot of anatomists in
Neuroscience do they take the data and
they try and write stories about how the
brain may work based on the anatomy that
we that we see and I think this is a
supremely explainable approach so now
most recently now just just just to go
back like in this area it's really at
the intersection of uh of artificial
intelligence explainability where where
we ask what is it that we can uh that we
can explain and um and ultimately in
your science one more thing we don't
really just want explanations but we
prefer certain explanations to other
explanations specifically what we often
want from explanations is that they have
a sense of causality that they allow us
what makes what happen because what
makes what happens is is in a way how we
Define understanding is scientists we
want to see how the world is kind of a
set of units that are connected to one
another they do something with one
another and it's important in
Neuroscience for medicine it's important
for AI because ultimately we want to
choose actions if we build artificial
intelligence that ultimately make us
more successful and make our company
more successful and hopefully that make
the lives of us humans more successful
now briefly why is this all so hard if
we're interested in how one variable
affects another variable say the Lower
Blue variable to the higher level blue
variable the problem is there's
confounded there there's other variables
in the world or the brain that affect
both variables of Interest now a lot of
AI people believe if well if we can just
Rec if we can just get enough data we
have all the confounders we can correct
for the confounders and all the effect
all the promps are going to go away the
slight problem is that in the world
there's also colliders variables that
are affected by both of our VAR abl if
we correct for those variables we make
things worse the problem is that in
reality a lot of confounders are
simultaneously colliders so that makes
it very difficult to think about
causality and I think it's a it's a
wonderful and Rich area where we really
now have multiple areas getting together
neuroscientists traditionally with the
interest in how the brain areas interact
the AI field and I want to just briefly
pluck the clear conference
that realizes that really in many cases
we want to have CLE understanding in the
world and lastly the explanations field
because ultimately we want not just any
explanation we want explanations that
actually get at causal truth so that I
hope sets up a little bit of what I want
to after hearing from our uh our two
other panelist what we want to see which
we what we want to discuss um now it's
it's time for
GU Che talk and I very much look forward
to
that thank you uh okay
so I need to take control do I have
control yes okay cool uh so thanks uh
Conrad um so um this is just the the
title of the presentation that was
pre-recorded and my intention here was
to emphasize an aspect that I think as
of um sort of conjugate complementary of
explanation and that is how to
use not only for the purpose of
explanation but even for the purpose of
uh uh developing more better models have
to use what we know already right and
Conrad already referred to this sort of
underlying
sometimes unconscious idea that all we
need is data right if we have enough
data we can solve every problem and that
seems to work
well um in the case of language models
that have probably everyone knows and
because there are know gazillions of
data out there to train some aspects of
of language
analytics but it doesn't really we don't
expect that it will work well with the
brain we have 100 billion neurons and so
many connections etc etc so it's you
know it's important to understand how we
incorporate uh what we know already
right um so I'll present a couple of
examples that to some extent
encapsulate uh the
way uh with many other colleagues we've
been thinking about this and
uh for several
reasons one of from the AI perspective
one reason is that uh language analytics
or language models or large language
models have really uh spearheaded the
revolution in AI that uh
we see every single day and and some of
the most
powerful AI models are language models
so the the language technology is
incredibly powerful in many
respects and also because um as an
uh computer scientists or mathematicians
or physicist we have tended to ignore
Behavior Uh as
something not as important
as you know microscopic mechanisms and
that is it I think it's a mistake and I
usually use the analogy from physics
right so in physics we didn't invent
statistical
mechanics and then develop
thermodynamics it was the other way
around we started with understanding how
Napoleon
cannons uh he it up I was carot
developed the idea of the microscopic
behavior of gases and then we were able
to go back to uh the molecules and say
you know temperature and the movement of
the molecules that's the right
connection
so uh that's the other reason we need to
do the thermodynamics of the behavior of
the brain if we have any hope of Ling
linking that back to micros
structures uh so how is this related to
what we are discussing here and and
these are a couple of examples of how we
are thinking of using what we know
already to have better models for
understanding
behavior and uh in one case
uh these two cases are related to what
happens with uh patients who have
schizophrenia uh patients or individuals
in general that may eventually develop
schizophrenia because they have some of
the
symptoms and typically the way to
characterize their behavior is to
evaluate uh what they're saying so an
expert evaluates what they're saying
sometimes
you um ask them to fill a
questionnaire where they have to say you
know
between one and
five uh how strong are your
hallucinations or between one and five
uh how often do you think about your
experience in yourself from outside
Etc uh what we are doing is using uh
these language models that allow you to
for instance compute how similar one
sentence is to another one paragraph is
to
another and then uh in one of the
studies we asked the experts the the
experts in in the experience of
schizophrenia in patients what do they
expect the patients to say in a
completely uh open-ended interview right
so patients speak freely and then we use
this technology to map what they are
saying to the targets that are designed
by by the experts right so in that case
we work with a group of experts that
they say we know it's likely they we say
this or that you know they were
wondering what happened to them
wondering about the sense of
agency and then we can we show that by
using this technology we can identify
precisely a preoccupation with a sense
of lack of
agency uh as in the completely natural
naturalistic way of eliciting uh
speech
um and then you know in the subsequent
study we generalized that and we went to
establish inventories questioners that
are used clinically or at least in
clinical
research and they have been validated in
terms of the community understanding
this is a very good way of asking what's
going on with patients
using scales in questioners of self self
assessment so we can repeat that in a
completely
open-ended uh uh setting for eliciting
the the speech of
patients and what one thing that is
interesting is that the signal to
separate for instance schizophrenics
from subal
schizophrenics is stronger and if
anything
is the opposite in direction to the self
assessment right so
which is a you know it's a different
problem it's super interesting but the
point is that we can use this
technology uh to both gain
knowledge uh but also at the same time
gain understanding because we are
explaining onto things that we already
know and they are already well
established
right apologies I think your slides
aren't advancing so
far
okay now you
[Music]
see the
one
okay okay I don't know yeah it it lost
yeah it lost control for some reason
okay um so another example and uh and
this is again going back to the brain
and and
uh but is In The Same Spirit as the one
before
is you know we were ask asking uh
how can we incorporate
knowledge uh in in what you know
whatever we know about the brain as cor
said you know we know a lot than we know
little uh and combine that with this
very obsc cure black boxes that uh in
terms of performance are extremely
powerful uh artificial neuron Network
models right deep learning you all the
very recent
models and this is one way right that
it's it's one possibility uh I don't
think it's the solution but it's a way a
way of thinking about the problem
is um you can take uh a functional data
right so fmri in this case we also use
calcium Imaging in the CRA fish and try
to uh learn a model that would predict
evolution of that uh that signal if you
if you see a section of it you know can
you predict the future and you can use
one of these deep learning models and he
does a good job but there's not really
much uh in terms of understanding what's
going on right so you you can you can
read really uh come up with a good uh
outter Rive model um so what we did was
to say well if uh some in the guts of
these models there are
specific uh assumptions about how the
units that you're modeling are
interacting with each
other uh if you do something like a
model based on what we know about the
behavior of small networks of neurons
is it possible to do something that it
will be more interpretable because the
Dynamics of those a small number of
neurons you know when you're
modeling uh will allow you to come up
with something that is more related to
what we know and what happens is that uh
if you just do a more classical model
where you
replace uh the the units in in your data
with these model units uh you do
something good but it's not as good as
the black
box but if you train the black
box with one of these models then you
get something that is even better right
so at least at the very least you can
get uh an improvement in the way you can
model because you have Incorporated
existing
knowledge uh in the field
um and then let me um conclude
here um and again this was taken from
the
talk uh on the theme of how to
incorporate knowledge so what we
saw uh and this seems to work well at
least with language model is that uh we
can create new insights BAS Bas on
pre-ex model so we can back we can map
things to to what we know using uh what
otherwise are sort of Black Box
models uh it has in the case of language
it has some advantages because you can
use naturalistic
settings
uh but and this is something that you
know the last bullet I added at the
end um we're experiencing the phenomenal
change in AI capabilities
and everyone probably knows about CH GPT
today and I think the way
we think about explanations may change
right so the things that are happening
with chat GPT and jbt like algorithms is
that you can engage in an iterative
interactive interpretation and
explanation with all the caveats that we
can can think of but that's something
that is new and you know we are just the
beginning so the way we think about
explanation may be changing because of
this and with that I
stop wonderful thanks so
much you very much looking forward to
the presentation of changu
then great um there might be some slides
not shown but uh feel free to ask any
question
to J um in the question and answer and
with that I will start my talk uh it's a
quick summary for the content that I
gave um during the 30 minute recording
um and in this talk I would talk about
neur Network models of visual learning
and
development so um in this talk I will
talk about how we can reverse engineer
basically the objective function that we
use to train the model models um so that
the models would learn and develop just
like how neurosystem how humans how
other real animals will do okay and I
focus on um visual system so visual
system is a complicated system um it's a
processes a lot of inputs in our Real
World um earlier work have shown that if
you change artificial neural networks um
to do categorization meaning that given
an image um to tell whether it's a dog
or cat or other sematic categories if
you train a network to do that um the
networks will end up being a good model
of the vual visual passway U which is a
passway in our brain that that's
responsible for like static image um
categorization or
representation um but these networks um
cannot explain the visual learning and
the development why is that I'm going to
list three reasons the first and also
the biggest reason is that they require
many more labels to during learning and
then humans what I mean by this is that
these networks are typically trained on
large scale data sets such as image net
which contains 1.2 million labels
there's no way that human infants or
like um primates for example can receive
so many labels so their objective
function is really wrong um in giving
the learning and the development
trajectory so second reason is that they
are not trained on the correct data um I
mentioned that they were typically
trained on like image
which contains static images and all of
these um uh multiple instances of the
same category but infants regularly see
like the same instance but maybe from
different viewpoints and also they see
continuous stream of inputs instead of
static images so this really makes um
them the worst model of the uh learning
and the development the third reason
which I will explain more later is that
they trained in a so-called offline
fashion meaning that the models are
typically trained um uh uh in repeating
the same data over and over again to the
models okay with that I will then talk
about three projects uh my collegers and
I have worked on to address these three
issues now the first project is about um
changing the objective function to be
unsupervised rending functions now this
means that we need a new objective
function that don't leverage or don't
use any labels at all this algorism
typically called unsupervised learning
algorithms and earlier versions of these
algorithms prior to like year 2019 or
2018 were really not good enough they
were not good enough um in uh doing
Downstream visual tasks they were also
importantly not good at modeling the
visual system this is why at 2018 or
2019 there is this new family of
unsupervised learning algorithm called
contrastive learning algorithms and they
work better so let me give you an
example of how this algorithm works by
talking about one algorithm that I and
my colleagues developed called a local
aggregation algorithm so this algorithm
trains the networks to do semantically
aggregation within the input space what
I mean by this is that it will develop a
network representation so that the high
level output of the network will
aggregate the current inputs and also
some close neighbors we identified in
the EMB banding space and making them
farther away from background neighbors
meaning similar but not that
similar so after doing so we find that
these methods um propose uh uh model The
Venture visual passway better than
earlier methods it also achieved the
good performance and also the best
performance when it was published um on
typical computer vision
benchmarks so that was the first project
uh we now don't need the labels as I
mentioned that they were still trained
on different data and so the previous U
network still were trained on image net
which is very different from what
children perceive during their
development and this is why we use
another data set that's much closer to
how humans actually develop during their
um early lives which is the ccam data
set this data set is collected by having
head cameras on children and collecting
basically videos of their real life
interactions now this video dat this
data set consists of videos and
therefore is very different from the
previous data set that use to train our
networks this is why we develop a new
algorithm um to learn from these videos
we call that V VI algorithm the video
instense embedding algorithm um the
general idea of this algorithm is that
we will leverage the temporal
information within the videos um and we
use shorter temporal events to aggregate
the um the frames together will separate
the representation of these frames from
the representation for other temporal
event that are not close to them so
after doing that we find that this
algorithm leads to better neuro
productivity on the virual visal passway
when train on ccam data set than other
methods so this really shows that this
way of leveraging the tempal information
through aggregating the things through
aggregating the temporal frames are
really
powerful now I mentioned that the models
are still training in so-called offline
um learning so the third approach I will
address this question by changing the
learning to an online learning fashion
um so the offline learning fashion is
really wrong especially if we want to
compare the intermediate checkpoints of
the models to the intermediate points of
children development because models see
all the data at the beginning but humans
for example at age of four they see part
of the data of the whole development
trajectory so to address this difference
um we aligned the model and the human uh
learning uh presentation order meaning
that we present the videos recorded from
children in the same order um to the
models here the Apple number represents
um the uh uh the presentation order or
the learning order of the models now if
you do that and also within one apple
you will present the frames to the
models at the same order of the being uh
frame being recorded in the video now if
you do that there is really a critical
component now being needed which is
memory that's really because if you
don't have memory um networks will soon
forget the earlier inputs and therefore
lose the prior progress so we added a
memory module to the algorism to all
algorism and we find that that we needed
to learn partially from the memory but
not all from the memory because if you
just learn from the memory not paying
attention to the current environment
this will really makes the model
unresponsible um to the current change
now interestingly there is also a
paradigm change in the unsupervised
learning algorithms in the recent
several years about how memory should be
used earlier algorithm actually actively
uses memory by contesting when example
in the memory to the other making some
difference while recent algorithms no
longer need to do that so after
evaluating this all these algorithms on
how good they modeling the lifelong and
also the real time
different and the develop directories we
find
that actually better model the learning
Dynamic this is really a very surprising
finding for us because newer algorithm
typically outperform these early
algorithms on AI benchmarks however
earlier organms which actively use
memory which we
human is really a better model for human
learning in both real time and lifelong
learning
Dynamics now this is is that not the end
of comparing models to humans about how
they should leun and develop for now
what I have talked about is all on the
meaning that the most just perceive
visual inputs but we know that humans
perceive multiple modities um Vision
Lear for example um and this is also why
my current research project is about how
language development um can be modeled
by large scale such as trbt or
gpt3 if you have more interest feel free
to reach out and ask questions with that
iation and move to the next
slide wonderful there it was great to
hear about my my co-panelists it's it's
nice to see the breath of ideas that we
have there um I was going to start start
with a with a few points that I picked
up in your talks and then I want to like
us to go more broadly so maybe the first
question that t for you Shu I I I I I
admire how you bring this strong
ethological component into it like your
models are based on a consideration of
how the world is so I was wondering when
it comes to explanation and it I know
it's a big stretch from anywhere in AI
on your science to explanation but but
it's still like a big topic for our
audience I think to which level would
you say that ethological ways of
thinking offer a new way of explanation
where you could say maybe you can't tell
me how the AI system or my brain does it
but you can relate it to kind of like
what is that situation in which which we
are so I was hoping you could expound a
little bit on like the the links between
ethological ways of thinking and
explanation yeah um are you talking
about for example how these networks can
tell us about how brain system work um
this type of questions um so the the the
works that I presented is really about
um reverse engineering or understanding
what type of objective functions might
be the functions that humans use um
during their learning and the
development in real life that means for
example um we need to find a way um to
group the visual stimulus into different
in into semantically meaningful like
classes um categories here categories
are really not the semantic categories
that we usually talk about like dogs or
cats they might be more abstract and
these things are like doable meaning
that we don't need ad like uh access to
like supervision or labels that we um
should not have access to in our real
life and these things can um what I have
shown in my work is that um if we do um
this type of training in the neural
networks they indeed lead to
representations that are similar um to
the visual system so what I would argue
that um this tells us that what type of
representation um can be generated with
this um objective function and this
makes this objective function one of the
candidates in how humans might develop
their visual
system so so then the objective function
becomes the Prime objective of
explanation
like I'm just trying to like like push
you into the explanation corner like um
at some level if you can write down the
objective function then the idea is that
that objective function will be compact
the self-supervised learning goal will
be
Compact and then by being so we can
build systems around them like would
that be a fair
characterization right it's like saying
I would not I would I would say for
example the brain system the Dynamics of
the brain system is to optimize certain
things is to optimize certain criteria
and then using that high level idea we
would be able to understand how these
Dynamics unfold um what are the specific
Dynamics functions for this target for
this objective function and of course
like this is something like a middle
level explanation it's not like the
bottom level like how each synapsis
how each of the synapses will change um
to reflect this objective function to
like adjust this that's definitely
another question that we should continue
to explore and continue to
investigate one wonderful so so I wanted
to push gu on on more or less the same
point like you're using uh Ensemble
methods in the
end where is would you say this is a
place where where there's something
about about the architecture that that
that is ultimately the explainable
component where where where would you
where would you how would you describe
how explanation comes into your work
um it's a very good question you know in
to some
extent what I presented
today
is s of kicking the can down the road
because you're pushing back the
explanation
onto what we
know as you know as experts right so
what we understand is relevant and
actually that's been quite a bit
of a big part of my work and it is
trying to understand how a clinician a
psychiatrist or neurologist makes a
judgment and create an algorithm that
will try to replicate that so the
explanation is
essentially uh is push back onto uh oh
sorry
um push back onto
uh the the expert in the field right so
it's giving an analytics uh giving a
number to the intuition of for instance
what it means to um to have a distorted
experience of the self uh in in a person
with schizophrenia or schizophrenia
Spectrum um and you know that
is what these models allow us to do
right is to provide a numerical
counterpart to the subjective experience
of the person and the subjective
Judgment of the expert right and in that
sense that is what in in this context
explanation means is just show that
there is a a common and the is the
objective objectification of the
subjective Judgment of subjective
experience by saying well we can put a
number to it and we all agree that we
are measuring the same thing incomplete
as it might be or to the extent that
reflects the the the experience of a
particular symptom for instance right uh
and and
that is how I think about explanation in
this in this context
right um great so so let me push more on
the point now relating that to knowledge
so you can say knowledge is a
specific it's it's a specific piece of
an explanation for you now like can can
you can you maybe like go a little more
into details about the role and and
function of knowledge in the process of
explain
explanation right
[Music]
um at the end of you know one way of
thinking about explanation
is
uming you know mapping something new
onto what you already know right and
that so referring to uh a particular
phenomenon onto the coordinates that you
have already
built uh in your mind right so
and again this
is we lost going right uh he will be
back soon yeah yeah right
um I think you can continue uh right
yeah he he's back I'm back yeah
um and and again in when we are talking
about for instance behavior in
particular it's is I I think it's the
thing that we can do is you know what we
have established we have established as
a community as you know as a culture you
know what it
means uh to
have for instance a a um an experience
out of body experience in someone with
with the sosic
Spectrum and the fact that we can talk
about it and the the fact that we can
discuss and have an a common
understanding what it means explanations
in this case it it simply means we have
a way of poorly as it might be measure
that and understand that we can apply
the
same um the same ruler to different
people and obtain something that is
similar and and sort of the know the way
the way I think about the difference
between subjective and objective
objective is that which is common and we
can all understand right then language
is essential part of that right so it in
this cont that's how I explain sorry
that's how I understand the concept of
explanation referring that to a common
objective ground right of things in this
case things that are inherently
subjective like the experience of self
that the see we can talk about and have
a common understanding so that's for me
the way I'm thinking about this what
explanation is in this case right
referring referring something to a
common background of
understanding uh one wonderful I now
want to focus a little bit away of the
core of explanation and talk a little
bit about more the Technologies in our
space and I want to start kick this off
with the question of Donan AA who asks
specifically into the direction of
changu of the difference between offline
learning in online learing and I think
it's an important technical detail that
that that suddenly neuroscientists
almost never discuss why can't you give
can you give us a little bit of a
background about that and then talk
about the the difference and advantages
of the two of them sure sounds good so
offline learning is really a learning um
I would call it curriculum that's
typically used by computer science or
artificial um intelligence community the
way this learning um happens is that it
will first collect all the data that's
available for example imagine a human
going through um um multiple years of
life and uh let's say 100 years of life
and all this experience like what
offline learning will do is to collect
all these years of experience together
and then use this all these uh
experience randomly select segments from
them and then present them to the models
to help them train at the beginning so
the problem um and the um it's a
powerful learning curriculum um because
um when you do this um you will have
wider access to a larger diversity of
different stimulus and therefore um your
learning will be like situated to
fulfill multiple demands but this is not
how humans learn um because humans need
to face a continuous stream of data um
like uh going through their um all their
perceptual like uh uh modalities like
eyes um like vision for eyes and the
auditory um for ears for example and all
these inputs actually happening together
happening in a continuous um fashion
instead of like accumulating all the
things and then like shuing them and
then presenting them um at the beginning
so humans needed to do on learning this
is actually ecological um like a
constraints um to humans and we find
that models when they when they are
evaluated in the online learning fashion
they will be like um uh less powerful
than the models evaluated in the offline
fashion evaluated on this typical
computer vision benchmarks um however um
these models evaluated in the online
fashion will also be more humanlike um
and also it will place a stronger
constraint on how the models should run
from this continuous data stream so that
the objective function will also be
closer to how humans
live um so this is basically my answer
to this offline versus online learning
question the high level point is really
that humans need to do online learning
computer system can Leverage The offline
learning but that's not something humans
can
do oh we lost we lost your voice
yeah con I don't think we hear you oh
okay here's here's my voice back and I'm
three years into four years into the
pandemic and I still don't know how to
click the unmute button um which is
which is a little a little sad but what
I was just going to say is it sounded a
little bit as as if online learning is a
bad thing in a way like all biological
beings have to do that now because and
it's a good thing in a way because the
future is different so it's not just
just that we want to have access to all
of that it's kind of like what I'm
learning right now in this debate is
much more important for this debate than
maybe my May 49 years of Prior
experience into that so there's there
like it's really complicated space in
how we should be thinking about this
exactly exactly and this is why my work
actually Compares models in both the
lifelong and also the real time learning
realtime learning Dynamics humans do
learn in real time like we are learning
in sitting in this um debate and this is
like how humans will pay attention to
the current context and therefore like
um ad adapt very rapidly to the current
context and humans do that because they
have this online learning if humans just
have offline learning they want to be
able to do that so this is definitely a
benefit of
the so uh Conrad I have a question for
you or or a request for comment more
than a question I I was interested by
the example of of the uh of the
processor that he used and um I find it
interesting because it opens the
question of of know
does the ability of building something
means that we understand it right and it
is a lot of question because I know by
by way of being an IBM I know people
whose work is to
simulate CPUs after they have built
because even after we build them we
don't know how they're going to work
right yes I'm of course with you there I
mean the the statement of course goes
back to fine and what I can't build I
don't understand but you're obviously
right that what I can build I can most
suddenly not understand I mean like try
explain sh gbt to me how it really
process this information it it's it's
mindboggling at times so so so so in
that sense yes I mean like I'm I'm 100%
with you that basically being able to
build it doesn't mean we we understand
it in fact there's there's really a prom
that in domains with high complexity
like human
society biology bacteria but also
nervous systems that they even if we
could they would soak up so much
information from the environment and
arguably like your microprocessor the
actual microprocessor soak up
information
from physics all the way down that that
that we that that understanding is much
more complicated than than just having
the equations
there it's it's a great question now and
this is actually a wonderful place to
wrap up this overall panel I had great
fun I think we all agree that in a way
we at that surface now we're trying to
we're here in this space where three
really interesting communities meet the
explainability community the neurosci
science community and the AI Community I
liked how the two of you were covering
different parts of that space and I hope
that I covered like yet another corner
of this but but I think it's clear to me
I I I expect it's clear to the audience
is well we're just scratching the
surface there because it's this
incredibly Rich basic neuro human brain
complete Quest that we are on uh we have
to wrap up roughly at this time so I
want to thank the two of you again and
give the word back to the organizer of
labroots who will want to give us a few
last
messages well gentlemen I want to thank
you very much for this informative
presentation and such important research
before we go I do want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years until March 88th 2025 labrats will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay thank you again gentlemen and
we encourage all of you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time take care everyone bye
bye